[Music]
hi I'm Jody shield and I'm so excited to
be working with Glamour magazine on our
three mindful minutes video series in
this video I'm gonna be teaching you how
to wake up and start the day in the best
way possible the way that we start the
day really shapes the rest of the day
that we have so it's really important
that we are able to start the day off in
the best way we've all been there
waking up from a funny night's sleep
where we've had crazy dreams or we've
gone to bed feeling really stressed out
from the night before when you wake up
in that way it's common to feel a little
bit dazed and confused almost as if
you're kind of out of the body in some
way so what I do is I sit up in bed
proper cushion behind me and I take
about two or three minutes to really
take some big deep breaths in and come
into my body so I feel really present
and here and the way that I do this is I
gently close my eyes and I take one hand
in a fist and I very gently tap on my
collarbone and while I'm tapping on my
collarbone I take some really nice big
deep breaths in so how about you have a
go with me right now close your eyes
take one hand in a fist
and gently tap on the collarbone while
taking some really nice big deep breaths
in
and what you'll find is the tapping
opens up the airways much more and you
get oxygen into your cells and tissue in
the body really quickly and so you're
able to really open yourself up and take
nourishment and energy into your body
something else that really works for me
is by placing my hands on my hips and
taking some really nice deep breaths
into my hips it brings me into my body
really really quickly